alors je vous parlerai je veux faire une
interview spéciale pour vous qui
s'appelle l'interview sans intérêt ça
c'est cool
on ne bouge pas pendant le jingle
vous savez bien ne pas bouger mois on
n'a pas bougé serve de pion à une
question chacun donc l'interview sans
intérêt on commence avec vous cadre est
ce que vous savez coudre
intéressant oui avec les pieds seulement
bien
olivier vous préférez la mer ou la
montagne
difficile comme question prend le temps
de répondre
la montagne la montagne
cad est ce qu'elle vous a rappelé qu'
est-ce que vous aimiez les cols
difficiles qu'ont question
la montagne
la montagne est ce que quel est ce que
vous avez dit balle pour le kabyle
n'a pas vraiment fait julien si je dis
bah ouais c'est l'interview sans intérêt
pour vider mes poches parce que sinon
vous allez avoir des petites surprises
format 100 g sur moi donc
on n'est pas chez comédie là j'ai pas
dis balle vous avez pas dit balle pour
lequel vous avez vu les résultats du
référendum c'est incroyable oh la la
c'est l'interview sans intérêts
évidemment
vous êtes dans la voiture
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai pas de voiture
c'est très bref essayer des trucs en
même temps je teste
cannes vous y croyez à ce truc vous
car les oliviers
107 les clients ideo
pour une nouvelle interview il s'appelle
l'interview sans intérêt sans intérêt
mais j'adore cette musique aussi
voyez avec sauver la vie mais vivement
le genre ne pas bouger les tue mais une
musique qui fait bouger ben moi c'est ça
aussi ça c'est pour ça que c'est
difficile bien sûr que non bis in verra
bien alors
intervenu sans intérêt si comment ça va
comme lundi
réponse sans intérêt je crois oui si la
commune sans intérêt comment ça va tuyau
de poêle
tu penses à kuala
à mercredi prochain mercredi 28
je pense et j'espère que la prochaine
question j'aurais de la répartie ma
rentrée
c'est pas possible parce que c'est une
interview sans intérêt cette vérité tu
vois là t'as pas trop chaud là non j'ai
mis un pull pour faire style je suis
branché mais free j'ai chaud quand même
vous faites quoi pour les vacances
normalement pour l'instant rien n'est
prévu réponse 60 et réduirait sa mère
souhaitait bien comprise et
tu vas quand tu reçois fous moi de mes
vacances ouais je n'ai revu lundi voit
alors bien franchement bien ses réponses
sans intérêt c'est ce que moi je suis à
fond dedans moi je trouve sérieusement
oui monsieur nous avons vu nous l'avons
revu et depuis quand il n'a pas plu
comme ça il n'a pas plu comme ça ça fait
bien la derwent qu'il a plus et 1 740 tu
as voté dimanche ouais on s'est bien
passé loin de là nous et je m'entends
c'est dingue non ouais franchement c'est
surprenant après 24 ans quoi
tu préfères la mer ou l'océan on perd
des spectateurs mois mais ces
enfants me dire parce que sinon moi je
peux balancer des trucs avec du cul
dedans on veut mettre cul dans ma phase
de ma réponse si tu veux vas-y tu as
peut-être faire l'amère du cul et ben je
sais
pas c'est pour choper l'audience des
chaînes
elle te rappeler
non mais j'attends énormément parce que
j'avais pas débranché mon téléphone là
je vais le brancher après et peut-être
qu'elle va rappeler mais si elle est ce
un message je vais aller à fond dans ton
truc mais si elle est ce un message sais
pas si je le rappellerai parce que très
honnêtement à donner ton numéro ou pas
j'ai donné mon numéro treize années
lequel c'est un faux pas le coup qu'elle
renage parce que de toute manière on
sait quoi ouais tu es avec moi ouais
mais tu y crois toi ce truc absolument à
tous tout ce que vous dites monsieur je
vous crois
hélas une question sans intérêt mais
qu'est pas de moi l'idée d'un intérêt
man
vous aimez les chiens j'adore je trouve
ça génial un chien c'est des poils c'est
ces dépôts que ce n'est pas de céder
yeux ça court ça rediff j'ai vraiment
hâte à fermer le gaz avant de partir
j'ai pas de gaz tout et tout et au laser
chez moi
après oui on va faire une interview sans
intérêt dans la bouche
bouge pas pendant le tueur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d'origine galles dès que ma fille est
partie est quand même beaucoup moins de
bafici rêve
dis moi tu a rappelé la meuf là non ah
bon
sa part appelé non non je comprends pas
d'ailleurs pourquoi ça parce que je vais
pas fidèlement numéro un peut-être
tu combats parfois ouais c'était là la
mer ou la montagne
pas jeter à la mer mais ouais c'était
moi il va atterrir en d'autres mains
trop de chance sur le trop de sable trop
neutre au deuxième pas ouais
ouais
t'as pas fait pas dix balles pour le cas
dit
non je fais rentrer du fioul ouais j'ai
fait rentrer du chemin
on est suffisamment pour le mois de
décembre un moment que pour janvier
normalement on est sur le coup de tête
il ya monsieur cousin qui va passer pour
en déposer ça va
je fais tout le monde en parle la
voiture avait fermé la fermeture non
justement j'ai mon arme qui marchent
plus je ne suis quand même pas aller où
je me suis foutu au parquet à moi ça va
alors il ya un gardien agathois sinon ça
va moins ça va je fais tout le monde en
parle oui oui ça va t'as pas vu ma
personne non
je la trouve plus ça se passe bien toi
moi ça va tu fais quoi en ce moment tout
le monde en parlera ouais d'accord
mais tu y croies se trouve toi non pas
trop c'est pas ses parents comme ça il
ya quelque chose qui me dérange dans ce
très beau jeu c'est plus sympa non non
non non
[Applaudissements]
je me suis longuement hésité mais des
chiens moi je me suis posé la même
question hier
et puis j'ai glissé sur un truc et puis
je me suis dit que j'aimais pas les
chiens savants toi ça se passe bien je
fais toujours d'en parler bien sûr que
tu en penses que ça sent bien disent
bien des chemises la tullaye où j'ai
acheté chez d'infliger chemisier
chemisier ben je me suis dit que bon il
fallait un petit peu
à l'aise là dedans ça va je me sens un
petit peu crispé tu vois mais ça ira
bien pas chaussé a pas trop donc pas
trop chaud en même temps il fait chaud
ici ouais je me tenais la chemise de
seine ouais ça se passe bien je fais
tout le monde en parle mais tu vois ça
s'organise bien c'est vrai ça va ça
marche bien méchant qui maquille marqué
pour longtemps pour les questions
non mais c'est pas pour lui fait tu fais
quoi alors pour les fêtes par exemple
noël ouais et je vais probablement
acheté à sa fin
allez on n'embauche pas pendant meeting
âge
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
préfère les chiens les chats
les deux mois je que les chiens les
chats s'entendent bien
je suis pour la paix dans le monde
et a fermé la voiture là je la la je
suis venu en taxi j'ai laissé ouvert
d'ailleurs il m'a appelé il m'a dit faut
fermer ces bébés je suis revenu j'ai
claqué la porte c'est fou non
ça moi ça me troue le cul
moi aussi c'est dingue ouais hein
complètement j'avais un sens c'est cette
scène c'est parce qu'on pourrait parler
des heures et c'est ça la vraie télé et
oui c'est pas crever quand tu te
réveilles toi
moins que quand je me couche mais
d'ailleurs ce matin ouais je me suis
levé j'ai pris mon petit déjeuner debout
j'avais la flemme de morat soir je suis
resté debout comme ça je suis allé me
coucher après ça m'intrigue le truc que
j'ai à dire que du regret et étaient
parents que c'est le téléphone ouais ça
ouais on appelle tous les jours ils me
demandent ils me disent alors ils ont
fait rentrer du fuel pour l'hiver dubois
et tulle a retrouvé sa personne
d'ailleurs je voulais te demander parce
que c'est pas si toi a fallu bien mais
la dernière fois à la personne c'est toi
tu m'as dit une fois la perceuse ouais
j'suis pas bricoleur ouais mais bon j'ai
envie de faire une perceuse et je te les
prêter ouais c'est moi qui ai pas la
mienne en plus c'était celle de tu crois
ce truc le truc ah oui oui
normal map a rappelé l sa part 1 contre
moi j'étais atteinte d'une autre fois
devant le restaurant et j'arrive et je
suis en temps restant j'ai dit je
connais tu irais hardy sourit marié pas
et alors je suis ressorti comme quoi des
fois
il est bon dans l'intéressante intérêts
dans ses très bons donc benoît où j'ai
fait beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'interviews ces dernières semaines vous
êtes un petit peu voilà vous avez
peut-être un petit peu marre donc on va
faire une interview sans intérêt
le ray haute visibilité
de fermer la voiture j'ai fermé la
voiture je les fais lavelanet dans le
garage ce que j'adore les bagnoles vous
le savez et je suis très gêné d'avoir
une vilaine couleurs pour la voiture
t'as pas vu ma personne je n'ai pas vu
sa perceuse non
seulement déjà dû vous la posez vous
préférez les chiens les chats les chats
j'adore les chats
tu dors bien en ce moment je n'ai jamais
bien dormi
je dormirai bien mon repos finale
t'as pas vu ma mère cela me l'a fait
c'est cool non c'est très simple je
serai je suis impatient de voir si vous
allez faire cette interview avec anouk
aimée
alors ok mais vous avez vu
[Musique]
viard
est ce que vous savez coudre je couds
très bien ouais je recouvre à l'occasion
du pique un peu à la machine puisque un
peu à la machine vous préférez la mer ou
la montagne
la mer ces interviews sans intérêt comme
ça on n'a pas d'emmerdés la presse quand
vous étiez petit vous aimer l'école
un
oui oui je mets jamais l'école où elle
est bien bonne réponse non j'aimais bien
l'école et j'ai l'impression qu'on veut
qu'il me trouve à
10 dont jean-marie truffât dumas
perceuse oh non on a
préféré les chats ou les chiens
j'ai les 2 way et vous y croyez à ce
truc un peu ouais j'aime bien je préfère
y croire que de ne pas y croire hec -
moins solide ouais tu mange beaucoup de
frites
répond pas c'est un con
dis moi tu as ta pensée a fait quoi sur
les toits
faire rentrer du fioul ah oui tarn et le
gaz
mais il le faut ça c'est bien ça c'est
la phrase branché en ce moment j'ai eu
des fautes et en boîte de nuit et il
faut que je rentre parce qu'ils livrent
le fumeur à 8 heures ça fait super
branché dis moi ça va toi en ce moment
il est nul ton interview sans intérêt
comme ça n'a pas dans merde qu'est ce
qu'il pense de la falaise
les corrections de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux